this is the beauty of Dubai is just
because it's a city where we have all
nationalities of the world you know
everybody has his own anger his own
world he's on point of view on a
situation so if you bring everybody in
the same place you will see like
fireworks of creativity I'm gonna live
it I am Daniel Dravot
together we are architects and
photographers our approach is to play
with respectives and geometry within an
urban landscape and thus architects we
travel the world exploring unseen
aspects of buildings so we can tell
stories to the image we are a journey to
meet with other like-minded and
inspiring creatives in Dubai yeah we
would meet with spontaneous content
creator Remy Abu chakra we meet with
Remy to share distich approaches and we
begin by taking in a bird's-eye P of
Dubai I'm in device in three years now
so a lot of people knows me here as a
French in Dubai I do my own content I do
from photo and video stop-motion I
believes anything that I can take from
my camera from my phone I like to to try
to find innovative content every day and
to the unique I think the ways in
fantastic city to create content you
have a lot of different places because
it is good and people already
experienced it but you want to try to
find a new angle actually to have your
own creation I don't plan too much
recorded the freestyle shoot I play with
light will shave with shadows with
motion I have this idea and I go on the
street I shoot it I do a quick edit on
my computer and post it it is this
impulsive style of rama's photography
that is so interesting to us the way his
mind works fast to complete a narrative
for his imagery is fascinating
I think your pictures are also very easy
to cut very you know very bold that you
can really see what he was looking for
but at the same time we are achieving
that in very different ways we have more
stage to a trickle while he is more
fresh and dynamic and quick the geometry
for you is super important because you
play a lot with symmetry for architects
oh yeah well it's impossible not to
think about those things we like to find
places that has the same kind of
pictures from the same distance the same
focal length when you change those
things a little bit maybe add some humor
or take a prop or a certain outfit or a
certain perspective or distance
everything in the frame is considered we
buy paint wardrobe and props
sometimes even make them a famous needs
it Dubai it's really easy to you know
step back a little bit you can take it
all in how the beautiful design and the
facades they have a much more creative
spirit in the design once you get up to
the top you can see how everything was
so taken care of and you can see all the
details see how everything was done to
be beautiful and geometric we've seen so
many unique aspects to divide skyline
we're visiting with Remi it's been
eye-opening learning about his approach
and comparing and collaborating with him
I think I'm a really hard worker I
worked like maybe 6 days per week I
really like the city for that you get a
lot of opportunities you can do your own
projects you can draw very fast and I
think this is the beauty of it
[Music]
everybody can be a content creator today
what's a content creator it's not just
me it can be you it can be you it can be
anyone I don't even know if I will be a
photographer in two years and I like
that it is this creativity that inspired
us to even create our own image while in
Dubai and we'll take various adventures
thinking on with us for future projects
I'm living the dream
Jennifer eyes
[Music]